au mois de juin il avait été l'un des
premiers à tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
aujourd'hui je prends la parole pour
vous parler avoue festivaliers car la
culture est le monde des festivals sont
en danger
ce directeur d'un festival de reggae
alertait après l'annulation des concerts
et la possible disparition des
travailleurs de l'ombre régisseur
ingénieur du son tourneur tous ceux qui
mettent en lumière les artistes ne le
sont pas ce silence
devenir notre avenir florent à 27 ans il
est intermittent éclairagiste sans
travail depuis le mois d'avril sans
perspective désormais lui qui croyait
pourtant et une reprise
elle intéresse comme une grosse période
le printemps aussi donc déjà on a fait
un peu le deuil du tout ça et l'automne
est aussi une grosse période d'activité
normalement et qui est en train de
disparaître fin tout le travail est en
train de s'annuler petit à petit coin
dans son dépôt lui aussi compte les
heures non travaillées spécialisée dans
le montage de scènes le voilà seul dans
deux mille mètres carrés là on voit tout
les trucs tout le matériel est là dans
son immense majorité
en théorie oui ça devrait être vidé et
et on devrait en plein en plein boom
moins les charges à payer les salaires
pour 6 personnes le loyer un défi de
taille pour ce jeune patron
malheureusement comme tous les
prestataires on est aujourd'hui à plus
de 80 % de perte de chiffre d'affaires
et nous la saison se terminant au mois
d'octobre on sait déjà que pour l'année
2020 c'est terminé donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut absolument que le
gouvernement mette en place des mesures
importantes de soutien toutes ces
entreprises
à l'autre bout de la chaîne les
organisateurs de spectacles ce directeur
d'une salle de musique craint un effet
domino si demain ce tissu il est
fragilisé où il disparaît on va être
très mal parce que nous une saucière un
établissement comme la rodia ne peut pas
travailler avec une lui dire une énorme
boîte d'événementiel qui pourrait faire
des prestations de soin d'éclairage
on est obligé d'avoir un rapport très
serré avec des fournisseurs locaux
ce soir et jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
cette salle de musique s'éclairera de
rouge en solidarité avec les entreprises
du spectacle